hello good morning the chancellor Jeremy
Hunt is set to unveil a budget aimed at
boosting efforts to get people back to
work and what he's calling a budget for
growth the chancellor is expected to
announce a major expansion of child care
support as well as other incentives to
help improve productivity but the day
will also be marked by a series of
Nationwide strikes as doctors teachers
and civil servants continue their
demands for better pay we'll hear more
about that day of action shortly but
first more on what we can expect from
the budget
well it's likely that support for energy
bills will be extended for another three
months all eyes will be on any
announcement around public sector pay as
thousands of workers continue to strike
it's understood the government could
increase the amount people can hold in
their pensions without it being taxed
it's expected free child care will be
expanded to cover one and two-year-olds
in England
and turning to business the government
has already announced its plans to
incentivize investment with 80 million
pounds allocated to 12 locations across
the UK
and defense spending will increase to 5
billion over the next two years with
more here's our Deputy political editor
Sam coats
[Music]
how do you reignite the British economy
right gentlemen what we're doing today
is you're currently your fitting task at
this Factory in Walsall they're
manufacturing the workers of tomorrow
Labor shortages are holding back
companies across the country I think
Marx what is currently surface grinding
to get the down to tolerance here they
train hundreds of Engineers young and
old the skills they need to fill the
gaps local businesses are are Furious
really that we've got this skill
shortages over recent years especially
during the pandemic you saw a lot of
people in the main redundant furloughed
or realize there were a such a point in
life where they could actually exit
engineer manufacturing and retire
so what we're trying to do here is
Achieve by reskilling them quickly to
come back into the sector
one of the big drivers of the UK labor
shortage is a rise in early retirement
the chancellor says he wants to get the
over 50s off the golf course and back
into jobs this budget will raise the
tax-free pension allowance to 1.8
million pounds a financial carrot to
keep the already well off in work for
those enjoying a round of golf here it
could be a hard sell I don't think
anything would have made me delay
retirement I think there's a lot of
people who would probably like to retire
early and I think I would call myself
living in the Golden Age where I
actually could if you've paid into a
pension for all those years and the way
that pensions are calculated it doesn't
make sense to stay on for a lot of
people you know most of us here are
probably in a fairly privileged position
but you know to a lot of people that
could make some changes like the
pensions changes possible in the budget
that will probably keep some people at
work but at the moment you know there
may be maybe retire cash for pensions
and for parents too an extra four
billion pounds which the government
claims will fund 30 hours of child care
a week for one and two-year-olds the
cautious welcome but questioned over
whether the Chancellor's Sons add up
investment at this scale could be a real
game changer for families who are
struggling with their eye-watering child
care bills however we do need to make
sure that it's funded at a level that
covers the true cost of child care the
authors of this budget don't expect it
to be a game changer measures on
pensions and on Child Care targeting the
same problem how to keep people in work
and helping the economy grow will it be
enough samcoat Sky News
well let's just bring you some news just
in before we talk to our political
correspondent Tamara Cohen and the
energy price guarantee this is a thing
that keeps households bills at a set
level it has been kept at 2500 for an
additional three months from April to
June the government's saying that this
should save a typical household
160 pounds it was widely trailed but it
has just been confirmed by the
government let's get more now with our
political correspondent Tamara Cohen
who's at Downing Street confirmation of
this policy uh tomorrow but what else
are we expecting to see in the budget
today
morning Jane well that is part of a
package that the chancellor hopes will
help people who are struggling with the
cost of living they believe it will take
another three months for the drop in
wholesale gas prices to feed through to
people's bills so you'll get additional
support with those but that is to
prevent bills Rising by as high as they
would have done as for how life will be
easier the chancellor has said that one
of the aims of this budget is to get
people back to work and we learned last
night that he's planning a big expansion
of free child care for one and
two-year-olds who will get 33 hours if
both their parents are working in the
hope that parents and even grandparents
will be able to either come back to work
or increase their hours and give the
economy a boost now of course parents
and of course providers will be looking
very carefully at whether the numbers
stack up there but potentially that
could be a very big game changer for the
conservatives as for those who don't
have young children or won't benefit
from these pension changes the
chancellor has made very clear that
getting inflation down is his priority
so there won't be big tax cuts for
individual taxes and he also is not
minded to reverse the rise in
corporation tax that's coming in in
April that's been the folks of a lot of
grumbling from conservative MPS when he
talks about this being a budget for
growth he will introduce other business
tax breaks particularly for what he
calls the businesses of the future but I
think the focus today in his first
budget will be whether he can make a
tangible difference either on the cost
of living or growth within the next 18
months before we expect there will be a
general election
okay tomorrow thanks very much well
don't forget we will have full coverage
of the budget here on Sky News with
Sophie Ridge presenting a special
program from 11 o'clock this morning
right through the budget and getting
lots of reaction as well
how we want to hear your thoughts on the
budget you can call us now on o20
81672200 to be part of a special
phone-in program to have your say and
ask our experts with any questions you
may have you can watch budget you'll say
at 7 pm this evening here on Sky News
meanwhile hundreds of thousands of
workers will walk out today in a
national day of action timed to coincide
with the budget
up to 150 000 civil servants working
across more than a hundred government
departments will be on strike for more
pay
today is the last of three days of
strike action by Junior doctors in
England which the British Medical
Association says has been supported by
more than 36 000 Hospital doctors across
the country
around 10 000 members of the rail
Maritime and transport Workers Union
will walk out for the seventh time in
London since this time last year as
theft drivers are also taking part in
their first strike on the London
Underground since 2015.
and teachers and University staff will
be on the picket lines today at least
250 000 teachers across England are
expected to walk out as well as seventy
thousand staff at universities across
the UK the schools Minister says
teachers have been offered talks to end
the strikes
well we wrote to the unions in February
uh offering them very serious
negotiations about pay the only
condition was that they poor strike
action and the National Education Union
unlike the nurses refused to accept that
had they accepted that offer we would be
in those negotiations right now as the
nurses are so we want to have a
settlement reached as swiftly as
possible we want to be around the table
with all four unions talking about pay
and Recruitment and Retention and the
workload of teachers but we do we can't
have those negotiations while strike
action is happening
well Alice Porter is at a picket line
with teachers in East London this
morning and Alice what are they saying
to that that they don't appear to be
willing to get around the table and talk
foreign
yes absolutely I mean Jillian Keegan she
wrote to the teaching unions yesterday
asking them to sit down and discuss pay
and reforms but as you were just hearing
there it was on the understanding that
industrial action was called off and the
Neu say they could not agree to those
preconditions and they only want to sit
down at the table when a pay offer has
been made the government's position is
very much look you've had a pay rise of
five percent last year we've put forward
a three percent pay rise but teachers
are saying that it's simply not enough
they're wanting a pay rise that is above
inflation with many teachers struggling
with the cost of living crisis
particularly those here in East London
so the government and teachers in
England are very much at this stalemate
there has been progress made in Wales
and in Scotland where industrial action
was paused in Wales we also as a revised
pay offer and it was called off in
Scotland so progress has been made there
but today and tomorrow we have got
strike action taking place across
England which is meant to impact almost
all schools here at mossborne Community
Academy in Hackney two-year groups are
not able to take place as normal because
of the industrial action
Alice thank you
the United States is still at odds with
Russia after military officials said a
Russian fighter jet hit one of its
unmanned surveillance drones in
international airspace over the Black
Sea the Russian ambassador to Washington
was summoned to give an explanation with
the two countries given very different
versions of what happened
at approximately 703 am Central European
Time one of the Russian su-27 aircraft
struck the propeller of the MQ-9 causing
U.S forces to have to bring the MQ-9
down in international waters
several times before the Collision the
su-27s dumped fuel on and flew in front
of the MQ-9 in a reckless and
unprofessional manner this incident
demonstrates a lack of competence in
addition to being unsafe and
unprofessional
you'll see that miss Catherine dodfret
has conveyed her concerns in the United
States concerns regarding this incident
and I hope that you have seen today
remarks by Mr Kirby and uh
part parole of State Department on this
issue nothing new
well our security and defense editor
Deborah Haynes joins me now the Russians
are saying nothing new here but how
significant is what's happened
it's hugely significant it's the first
time that we know of at least that the
US and Russia have had Direct contact
UM with each other since the the war in
Ukraine began and a U.S drone has been
forced out of the sky as a result
um it's landed in the Black Sea um it's
not believed that there are American
ships
um nearby which means that Russian
vessels would surely be trying to Now
find the wreckage of this drone and see
if they can glean any intelligence from
it
um it also underlines the risk of
unintended escalation around this
conflict where you have American British
other NATO allies operating their
aircraft the Russians are also operating
their own aircraft and in this incident
according to the American account the
two Russian fighter jets before they
collided before one of them collided
with the Drone were acting very
aggressively
um and recklessly dumping fuel on to the
Drone and perhaps to try to block out
the camera the Russians say that this
drone was operating near the Crimean
Peninsula which hasn't been confirmed by
the Americans
um but again aggressive Reckless action
according to the Americans by the
Russians and then this leading to a
direct collision and the Americans say
that the Russian jet was also damaged
the Russians have not confirmed that
they said that there was no direct
contact they claimed that the U.S drone
had some sharp maneuver and then
uncontrolled dive into the sea which
doesn't sound very plausible
um either way you came very close to a
manned Russian Russian jet crashing into
the sea as well so it really does
underline the risk and how this whole
conflict could spiral out of control
without anyone actually intending it to
Deborah thanks a lot
well in other news this morning more
than 200 people have been killed in
Malawi and Mozambique as Cyclone Freddy
continues to cause Devastation Malawi's
president has declared a state of
disaster in the country's southern
region Cyclone Freddy first developed
near Australia in early February and is
said to be the longest ever recorded
tropical cyclone
a tenth arrest has been made by police
investigating the shooting of a senior
police officer in Northern Ireland last
month a 45 year old man was arrested in
the Belfast area under the terrorism act
DCI John Caldwell was shot a number of
times after coaching a youth football
team in Oma in County Tyrone he remains
in a critical but stable condition in
hospital
a teenager has been arrested on
suspicion of possessing an explosive
near a railway station in High Wycombe
police and bomb squad Specialists were
called to the scene yesterday afternoon
when a member of the public reported
concerns about a resident in the area
the 19 year old lived on the road nearby
and was detained
the former Pakistan prime minister Imran
Khan is facing imminent arrest accused
of corruption charges he says he's done
nothing wrong and is the victim of a
dirty tricks campaign by his political
opponents while our Asia correspondent
Cordelia Lynch is in Karachi for us this
morning Cordelia what impact is this
having on the streets
foreign
well there's a lot of tension outside
Imran Khan's residence in Lahore still
there's been pitch battles throughout
the night uh still tear gas being fired
outside his residence as we speak and
his parties say that it feels even more
intense now Islamabad police moved to
Lahore to try and arrest him yesterday
but there was a big ground swell of
support from his team and we saw a great
deal play out there on the streets
there's deep concern Imran Khan is
accused of selling State gifts something
he denies now this is arrest is because
of uh he hasn't yet appeared before
court they are trying to force his hand
on that but he says and told me last
night in an interview that this is
politically motivated take a listen
they're doing everything to get out of
the elections or get me out of the way
because one way is to put me in jail the
other
is to have be killed I am a believer
you know who believes that life and
death is in almighty's hands so I'm not
really uh you know I I I'm in that way
but fatalistic so if I have to go to
jail I will I'm mentally prepared I've
got my reading material ready
now Imran Khan has said that he will
appear before court on the 18th of March
we don't yet know if that has been
accepted his team is currently in court
trying to get protective bail we await
to see the conclusion of that but
currently this is an intense stalemate
Cordelia thanks very much
well let's return to the budget now
Chancellor Jeremy Hunt will set out his
taxes spending plans for the years ahead
later on this morning with a focus on
growing the economy well with me now is
Justine Greening she's the former
conservative education secretary and
also former economic secretary to the
treasury good to have you here this
morning thank you for coming in despite
the strikes
um a big expansion of child care we're
expecting today could this be a game
changer for the Tories do you think I
think it's certainly going to be a key
Battleground at the next election uh
labor have talked about bringing forward
some ambitious plans I think for parents
most importantly for many this will be a
welcome change
um there's no doubt that for a
significant number of parents very young
children the cost of child care is
prohibitive I think the real challenge
for Jeremy Hunter's Chancellor is almost
not just this announcement but then
implementing it how is the child care
sector really going to be able to expand
to provide that that extra capacity and
do the numbers make sense for many child
care providers who'll say that really
their challenge is that the amount
they're being paid by the government per
hour of child care doesn't really match
the costs of providing it well because
when you're education secretary the
government brought in 30 hours for three
and four-year-olds but there was concern
that if it wasn't funded properly that
the costs will be passed on to those
with younger children and that that
happened do you think the government
will get the funding right this time I
certainly hope so and one of the
toughest areas introducing the policy
originally was to work out that rate for
providers because there are so many
different circumstances that they're in
as businesses it's actually quite hard
getting one rate that will suit all of
them in a sense
but broadly this policy has been a
success I think it has absolutely
supported often working women to get
into work I think this is now the next
stage it was always something I think on
our agenda even introducing the 30-hour
provision that you might want to go down
the age range so I think this is a
welcome step forward implementing it's
not going to be that easy but actually I
think for many parents it would be good
news are they just nicking Labor's
policy though oh come on I think um I
think the public just want to see change
on the ground and actually is that a yes
well I don't think it really matters as
far as the public are concerned no
party's got a monopoly on good ideas and
I think if a political competition means
that the good ideas are taken and
implemented then
that's good news for the public you
mentioned women and getting women back
into the workplace it is really crucial
isn't it what what would be the economic
benefit of getting a whole load of of
mums of one and two-year-olds back into
the workplace quickly do you think I
think it's twofold partly it's the
skills Gap that we got and and obviously
the the workforce shortages literally I
think the second thing is
hopefully meaning that parents and
particularly women often who this
affects that are already in work don't
perhaps have career disruption
that they wouldn't now get if they're
able to actually access Child Care
earlier so I think it it probably has a
double benefit for both the economy but
also women being able to to more easily
continue in their careers once they've
started a family which I think in terms
of gender equality is a really positive
step as well you're really passionate
about social Mobility do you looking
ahead at what's trailed in this budget
is there anything in it that you think
that's going to really make a difference
well the one thing I really want to see
is reform of the apprenticeships Levy
it's not just about getting more people
into the workforce it's also about
upskilling reskilling and allowing more
people access to opportunity
particularly younger people and I think
we all know how tough covert has been
for many people in the education system
so I think a a sensible set of reforms
the apprenticeship Levy would not only
allow great employers that want to spend
more of that Levy re-skilling and
upskilling people to be able to do that
I also think it would provide a lot more
opportunities for young people and in
the end Jeremy Hunt I think is quite
right to say this needs to be a budget
for growth that's what's being trailed
but the one thing that really Turbo
Charge growth in the UK is actually
improving social mobility and making
access to opportunity fairer in the
future than it's been in the past and
that is fundamentally about a talent a
skills agenda and that's what I really
hope we hear a lot more about today as
well what about public sector pay
obviously today is happening against the
backdrop of all these strikes the
possibility the public sector pay
increases could go up to around 5.5
percent within potentially in the budget
um would that be enough do you think to
Stave off strikes
well it's it doesn't look like it at the
moment obviously the pay review body
will look at almost the market economics
of this and I think at some stage an
agreement is going to have to be reached
by the government but when you look at
some of those key shortages we've got in
the public sector whether it's teachers
whether it's information whether it's in
the NHS actually again you look at
people who have left the workforce
perhaps slightly older I think we need
to change our mindset on the fact that
people come into careers and move up
actually people can reskill and retrain
even well into their 40s and 50s and
have successful long careers in some of
these key roles that are really
important for wider Society and also
potentially increasing the amount that
they could put into their pensions do
you think that will really encourage
people people like doctors perhaps who
might have retired early to come back to
work all the evidence seems to suggest
so and it just seems a sensible step to
me to make it easier for people who want
to keep working to do that and of course
post covered with more hybrid is working
actually this old-fashioned sense of
retirement that one day you're working
five days a week the next day you've
retired and you're doing no work I think
we all can see that as employers bring
in generally more flexible work
practices there is a real opportunity
for people to keep active keep working
but also do a better stronger job of
providing for themselves once they get
into older age we're also not expecting
tax cuts for personal taxes a proposed
increase in corporation tax we think is
still going to go ahead
um do you how do you think a lot of
conservative back benches will feel
about that do you think that enough else
will be offered for Jeremy Hunt to
square the sort of Circle of discontent
I think this is perhaps the most
challenging issue for Jeremy Hunt
um he's got this really tough tough call
hasn't he
um whose fault is that his now boss
Rishi Suna actually introduced it as
Chancellor and many of the people who
are now saying this is a terrible rise
we're part of Boris Johnson's government
that introduced it so I think the
substance of it in practice for growth
is that
I get that um
Corporation taxes going up I I think the
plan is that you'll backfill that tax
take with incentives for investment for
um for companies and so make it more
targeted to drive growth but actually in
a knowledge economy a lot of that growth
needs to come from upskilling reskilling
and talent and so actually the danger I
think for Jeremy Hunters he puts it all
into incentives for gov for companies to
invest in things technology but there
aren't the incentives there as well for
uh companies to invest in people and
actually that to my mind means you need
a more measured uh change of the
corporation tax because often it's it's
increasing tax that just literally means
the company looks as its wage Bill and
thinks well I can't I can't grow the
staff that I need so to pushing it up to
25 you don't think is necessarily the
best idea I think there needs to be a
balance and there's one area that I do
think Jeremy Hunt needs to think very
carefully about and that is for these
mid-sized companies so the headline rate
is going up to 25 for companies with
profits over a quarter of a million the
19 rate we've currently got remains for
companies with profits 50 000 or less
but for those actually quite small
companies earning 50 000 to a quarter of
a million profits they now have a rate
of 26 and a half percent
and so if you think these are the
fledgling potential Growth Company
companies that are going to really drive
the economy in the coming years I think
we really need to look at making sure
those businesses are supported because
going from a rate of 19 to 26.5 is a
huge rise for them to Bear okay Jesse
Brennan good to see you thanks very much
for coming in thank you
well let's take a look at how the papers
are interpreting what we're expecting to
see today they're all leading on the
budget the financial times expects
Jeremy Hunt to announce increased
investment in businesses in what's being
described as a budget for growth
crying out for help reads the front of
the mirror a message to the chancellor
to be fair to those who need it most
on the same subject the telegraph leads
with hunt faces Revolt over tax rise in
budget
the guardian highlights the 4 billion
pounds worth of child care funding
expected to be announced for the parents
of one and two-year-olds in England
and the times says more free child care
to get parents back into jobs
still to come on the show I'm going to
be joined by the Secretary General to
the public and Commercial this is Union
Mark sawatka and his teachers join the
picket lines I'll also be talking to
Kevin Courtney the head of the National
Education Union
[Music]
foreign
this morning a new study has shown what
we like and don't like in robots we'll
tell you more after the break
[Music]
now robots can be good for us they can
be useful but they have to look right
the Cambridge University study looking
at how effective robots are shows that
their physical appearance affects how
people work with them workers didn't
expect much from toy robots but even
robots that looked more human were often
a letdown apparently because although
they looked right they couldn't have
meaningful conversations
people are expecting too much of their
robots
now thousands of civil servants are
walking out today which of course
coincides with budget J I'm joined Now
by Mark sawatka the General Secretary of
the public and Commercial Services Union
which represents civil servants mark
thank you for coming in
um why today why is tricon budget day
well good morning well we've been
striking now since December because the
government's own Workforce has been
given the lowest payoff for anywhere in
the economy two percent
even though 40 000 of them use food
banks forty five thousand government
workers claim benefits because they are
so poorly paid and astonishingly today
the tax department hmrc that's on strike
for the first time a third of the entire
department is now on the national
minimum wage 10 pound 42 an hour for
collecting tax overseeing the minimum
wage and enforcing tax regulation so
we're on strike today to draw attention
to the fact that the government's
treating its own employees worse than
anyone else and of course we're joining
seven other unions on strike today
meaning there's actually six hundred
thousand public sector workers taking
industrial action your pay demands of
around 10 the government says it's just
unaffordable it's not a starting point
for negotiations
well there are no negotiations
um I've met the minister twice I've met
cabinet officials numerous times they
tell us they're listening the minister
actually told me he was moved by the
testimonies of his own staff that we
gave him that said they were skipping
meals that people are living in poverty
but two percent is what they've given
now food inflation last week was 16 not
the luxuries not caviar these are bread
eggs milk Staples 16 yep when you're on
the minimum wage and you're getting a
two percent pay raise industrial action
is the last resort we've asked for 10
because that's what inflation was but
what we've really said to the government
is put money on the table now and we
will meet you but they're refusing to do
that there there is a word that
potentially in the government we may see
the announcement of a 5.5 public sector
pay rise would that be a sensible
starting point that you could at least
get around the table and start talking
or if the government came and said we
want to start talking about 5.5 percent
and they agreed that that was going to
be backdated because this pay raise we
had of two percent came in March last
year then of course we would meet them
to talk about it we would say that 5.5
isn't enough we would certainly start
talking around it our key demands are
for the lowest paid and if I was to tell
you that we've just done a deal with an
employer in Scotland for some of our
public sector members that's delivered a
15 pound an hour minimum wage and has
got pay raises between 10 and 29 over
two years 29 for the lowest paid it
tells you that if in Scotland you can
make progress if in Wales you can make
progress if our firefighters can make
progress with local authorities why is
it only where it's the conservative
government at Westminster who makes the
decisions is no progress being made
anywhere so just to be clear you are
saying that a 5.5 rise would mean that
that you would get around the table but
only if it's back dated because my
understanding is the government saying
it won't back date anything so we must
have a backdated pay award because at
the moment people have had two percent
for the last year that's unacceptable
when inflation peaked at 13 due in that
period and we wouldn't settle for 5.5
percent but at least if the government
said we're starting there with that
money on the table we of course we're
getting to talks unfortunately at the
moment they've said two percent is all
you're getting we will not talk to you
so now we're seeing 135 000 civil
servants on strike today but I can tell
you that if after today the government
still won't talk later this week we will
be announcing a significant escalation
of that industrial action which we'll
really see I think disruption increase
because frankly not getting any pay
raises is not an option for the people
we represent but if the government do
say look you know you want 10 we'll
start talking at 5.5 but forget
backdated isn't now the time to just say
right let's just focus on the future and
let's get get sit down and try and work
something out
well we've made it clear that we will
turn up and meet them anytime
but what we're trying to be realistic
and say is we cannot walk away from
those talks with people having had a two
percent pay raise when they're using
food banks when they're claiming
benefits I mean I'm sure your listeners
would be staggered to know if they go
into a job center if they're getting a
pension or a disability payment or
Universal Credit the people dealing with
them are on the national minimum wage
people making decisions on Asylum
Seekers people who are collecting tax 30
percent of an entire government
department is on the national minimum
wage I think most people would find that
a scandal and would understand therefore
why two percent or even five percent
when your pay is that low does not help
you in a cost of living crisis of course
historically the Civil Service hasn't
been amongst the best paid in society
but a lot of people would argue that the
payoff is other benefits very very
comprehensive pensions when they retire
and it's something that they would say
well people know that when they go into
the Civil Service well that's a fair
point because I started in a civil
service 40 years ago in the southwest
valleys in a social Security office and
that was always the argument but 40
years on all of those extra things have
been eroded so now for example our
pensions are far from gold-plated in
fact the government had an independent
valuation that told them people were
paying two percent too much for their
pension but they refused to cut the
pension contributions so our pensions
have been eroded terms and conditions
have been eroded and the real proof of
this point is over the last 10 years
because pays gone down in real terms
every single year it's why now a third
of the entire hmrc and the DWP
departments that's 47 000 staff are on
their minimum wage they were not on the
minimum wage five years ago it's because
their pay's gone down everything else
has gone up and if people think that the
government's own employees are now
essentially getting the minimum wage for
administering Frontline Services I think
most people would find that shocking and
could see why we're taking industrial
action of course you know they are
alongside lots of other people who have
also seen their pays 4 all in real terms
it's not something that's just specific
to the Civil Service is it it's not
which is why so many unions are on
strike what I think is specific is we
have the lowest offer the lowest rates
of pay are the parts of the economy are
not having so many minimum wage
employees and I repeat the point that
when the government makes all these
announcements in the budget today
there'll be civil servants who deliver
it we'll collect the tax we will have to
implement the new laws we deliver the
Universal Credit we keep the transport
system running we check the passports at
the borders we have people in prisons
for 10 pound 42 an hour when forty
thousand are using food banks and
skipping meals it's a real Scandal and
the government know this is the case
which is why if you think everyone else
is going on strike when they've been
offered five or six percent I think most
people could understand why with a two
percent offer on those low rates of pay
this is really the last resort and there
will be a lot more of it unless the
government recognize it's a shame on
them that they are having such a level
of in-work poverty in the civil service
if they're turning a blind eye I can see
how passionately
this affects you it's really emotional
isn't it it's tragic because I see these
men and women who've dedicated their
life to Public Service who always go the
extra mile they were clapped in the
pandemic they went into work there were
people dying from covid because they
were in work delivering Frontline
Services yet now they're claiming the
benefits that they administer they're
going to the food banks with people in
the communities that they live but
they're delivering government services
they are government employees it's a
national scandal in my view and the
chancellor if you had anything about him
today would recognize it and give the
money that's needed which is not much to
give people a pay rise that means they
can spend money in their local
communities and that they're not living
in poverty Marx Walker thank you very
much thank you well teachers are also
striking today as part of their ongoing
dispute overpay join me now Kevin
Courtney joint General Secretary for the
National Education Union uh Kevin good
to see you too surely these strikes
can't go on for much longer can they
well what government should be doing is
sitting around the table and making
offers that can resolve the disputes so
that there aren't any more strike action
our members at this school and schools
around the country are on strike today
because they are defending children's
education they're seeing a situation
where in school after school that we've
got support assistance leaving special
needs support assistants leaving to take
jobs in supermarkets because they're
better paid well we've got specialist
classes without the specialist teachers
chemistry GCSE classes without teachers
qualified in chemistry where we've got
successions of temporary teachers all
doing a good job but where we can't hold
on to permanent staff and our members
across the country are saying the
government's got to invest in our
children's education so we don't want to
have any more strikes but we want the
government to make serious offers that
can resolve the dispute
Scotland and Wales though have managed
to reach an agreement with their
respective governments why do you think
you haven't
well we have reached an agree well we're
on the way to an agreement with Wales I
personally have been at meetings with
the minister in Wales Jeremy miles
talking about the situation around pay
and funding in schools in Wales and he's
been willing to meet and to reach
agreements so far uh Julian Keegan has
not been willing to do that she's not
making any offers to resolve the dispute
she's not making any offers to invest in
our children's education let's hope that
she will do that soon
she said that she will talk and will get
around the table if you pause the
strikes are you not willing to do that
just to start talks
well we didn't do that in Wales or in
Scotland and we've led to resolution now
with Julian Keegan's known the pattern
of strike action that we've had for
weeks and weeks and weeks she could have
been talking at any time to look for a
resolution to this but she has made no
offers to resolve the dispute that's
what we're calling out for her to do to
sit down and talk and make offers that
can resolve the dispute
what's your message to today let me just
say this
go ahead
my message my message single parent is
is we sincerely apologize for the
disruption to their child's education
today and the disruption to their home
life and their working life because uh
you know we know this is a problem but
what we're seeing is that parents are
actually supportive of the strike action
because they see there's a greater
disruption in their children's education
happening because of the underfunding
because of the Recruitment and Retention
problems and that's what we're curing
from parents and we're incredibly
grateful for the support that parents
are giving I think today we'll see tens
of thousands of teachers and parents
marching through London demanding that
there is a budget that invests in our
schools and colleges and invests in the
in the this generation of children this
generation of children hits so hard by
kovid and we need to invest in their
education right now the government's
turning their backs on them they
appointed sir Kevin Collins to give them
a recovery plan he gave them a plan they
ignored it he walked away they need to
invest in this generation of children
right now
is there anything you could hear in the
budget today that would make you cancel
the strikes
uh absolutely you know we don't mind how
the offers come so if there was an offer
of funding schools and paying people
properly who work in schools then we
could stop our strike action it's more
likely that they'll come through a talks
process and we are ready willing and
able to talk but we uh we think the the
pressure of our strike today the big
demonstration that we'll see in London
the degree of Parental support the fact
that there are many members of the
conservative party contacting us and
telling us they support us we uh I put
on my social media a letter from a
member of ours who says he was a royal
Marine for 28 years before becoming a
teacher always voted for the
conservative party and is coming on the
demonstration today because of how
disappointed he is in their gov in his
party's lack of investment in education
if I was the government I'd be worried
about that degree of support that our
industry Israel action has from across
the political Spectrum
okay Tim Courtney joint General
Secretary of the National Education
Union thank you very much
a striking image of a red fox has taken
the top prize of this year's British
Wildlife photography awards
here is the winning shot
pretty beautiful more than 13 000
photographs were submitted into this
year's competition but Charlie page has
been chosen as this year's winner he
says he wants to show the devastation
cause to local Woodland and Wildlife by
an increasing industrial landscape you
can see the fox now obviously in front
of the pylons behind it looks close up
almost like a painting it's a really
beautiful photograph
NASA has released an extraordinary image
showing a dying star taken with its new
Space Telescope the observation was one
of the first made by the web Space
Telescope after its launch in 2021 the
image shows gas and dust flung into
space by a huge star a hundred fifteen
thousand sorry light years away
scientists say that this transformation
is normally the last step before a star
explodes
well let's return now to the budget what
will the Chancellor's own MPS wanted to
hear from him well Harriet Baldwin is
with me she's a conservative MP and
chair of the treasury select committee
and thank you very much for coming in
um Jeremy Hunters perhaps ended up with
a little bit more Headroom than he might
have expected when um we were thinking
about where this budget might be back in
the Autumn
um are we in the right place to be
spending huge sums of money on things
like child care and defense
we'll see what the figures are later but
he has been lucky over the course of the
winter because of course when he
budgeted in November he was expecting
Energy prices to be higher than they
have been and so what I expect him to do
today and in fact one of the measures
has just been announced is to extend
that price cap for households for a bit
longer that's been worth about 700
pounds for households over the winter
should be worth about another 160 pounds
to households uh by the extension of
course that's really been helpful in
tackling this big economic challenge
that the chancellor faces which is the
rate of inflation and he will want to do
things today I think that reduce
inflation he will want to do things that
cut debt overall and he will want to do
things that grow the economy and
there'll be a real Focus I expect today
on growth but in in terms of the nuts
and bolts of the money potentially
public sector pay Rises up by 5.5
percent fuel Duty freeze 5 billion
Energy bill help that we just talked
about that could cost four to five
billion 5 billion defense pension
changes green investment over two
decades 20 billion the country is still
not in in an entirely stable economic
State can we afford this well I think
what he will do is he will make sure
that at the end when he sits down uh the
numbers do look better in terms of the
Outlook than they did before in terms of
reducing the debt that is definitely
going to be one of his priorities but he
has had some good fortune I've mentioned
the fact that it was a warmer winter
than he was expecting in November but
also he's made some of his Good Fortune
because he stabilized the markets last
November and by stabilizing the market
that means that the amount that the
government has to pay an interest that
will be quite a bit lower than was
expected by the office for Budget
responsibility when he made his
statement in November so I think he will
find that he is able to give some fairly
generous measures to the British public
while also focusing on that long-term
debt level coming down
so those are the things spending money
on one of the things that that people
may be interested in is pensions the
government is very keen to get people
back to work so we're seeing
announcements on child care and
announcements on pensions
um for those who don't understand it it
is complicated but if you have a lot of
money and you've managed to Save A Lot
in your pension there's a there's an
upper limit that could be increased we
understand
some have said though this is really
just going to affect those who are are
really very well off is is this
something that the government should be
focusing on
well I think he's got his mind on
Hospital consultants and Hospital
doctors senior doctors who are in some
of these big public sector schemes which
are very generous uh compared to what
people in the private sector tend to get
these days so I think you're absolutely
right that he will be looking at work
more generally so you know since the
pandemic we have had a recovery in the
economy but there are still not as many
people
who have returned there's more economic
inactivity than there was before and
also there's a lot of vacancies in the
economy and one of the things that he
will be hearing is that people have
retired earlier than they would do
normally because of these pension limits
particularly in the NHS and he will want
to make sure that the NHS Workforce you
know remains uh there until
later so I think that's one of the
things he will do
focus on work you were covering the
child care offer earlier and that will
be to help more people return to the
workforce after having a child but it
counterintuitive couldn't also be the
case that if you encourage more people
to put more money away
then they could also retire early as
well because they'll put more money away
and so they'll be able to stop working
earlier yeah I think he will have to
look at it in the round and we'll see
what the detail is in the measures
obviously next week on the treasury
committee we'll have in uh be a sort of
official commentators and then we will
have the chancellor himself in front of
the committee we'll be able to Probe on
some of the details but I think the
overall theme will be growing the
economy and helping more people return
to work and taking away some of those
barriers and disincentives that exist in
the benefit and tax system that prevent
people from doing those extra hours
public sector pay big a big subject lots
of strikes today we were told a while
ago that they wouldn't increase the
government wouldn't increase public
sector pay over five percent now being
trailed it could go up to 5.5 percent
the reason that they put that five
percent figure was because they thought
anything over that would fuel inflation
would you be concerned if they announced
a 5.5 increase well it is the Bank of
England's job to keep inflation down and
I I hope that we see the inflation rate
return to uh the bank of England Target
because inflation is obviously the worst
tax on the whole economy it's the worst
tax particularly on the very poorest in
society so it's absolutely essential
that inflation gets back down to its
Target level and I think in that context
the bank of England would not want to
see public sector pay spiraling in line
with inflation because then you get into
what's known as a wage price viral it
gets much harder to get inflation back
down again realistically what what
impact do you think do you hope that
this budget would have on interest rates
well I think you can hope that it will
continue to calm the markets in the way
that November's statement calm the
markets I think we are in an
inflationary environment it is crucial
that inflation gets back in its box uh
and so it you can't rule out the bank of
England having to raise rates further
than the four percent that they're
currently at
um but uh the chancellor will be very
mindful of that with the measures that
he announces today okay Harriet Baldwin
chair of the treasury select committee
uh good to speak to you thanks very much
well lots more chat about the budget
coming up in the next hour we're going
to be talking to Labor's Pat McFadden as
we build up to today's budget we're also
going to be talking to wildlife
photographer as well so lots still to
stay tuned to Sky news this morning Doug
away
foreign
[Music]